that a showrunner not only has been  approached but has verbally agreed to  take over the Reigns of the new Stargate  series  so why isn't it been announced was my  first question well apparently this  person is actually working and is  contracted to another show currently and  cannot agree any new contract to move  forwards with Stargate until that  contract is completed it sounds to me  like this is a contract with a  competitor and there'll be something in  that contract to say that they can't  have those official conversations at  least with another organization until a  contract comes to an end but I'm just  speculating